una fuente del elíseo le ha dicho a
france 24 que el presidente francés le
dijo a boris johnson que está listo para
relanzar las relaciones anglo británicas
británicas o francia si el gobierno de
boris johnson respeta el acuerdo
internacional del breaking y lo
implementa recordemos que en los últimos
meses se ha dado una nueva atención
entre londres y bruselas por el
protocolo de irlanda del norte
entretanto el gobierno británico ha
dicho que boris johnson ha expresado su
deseo y su pragmatismo de que se pueda
justamente implementar el break city y
proteger el acuerdo de paz de 1998 hoy
es otro día importante para la cumbre de
líderes del g-7 porque los huéspedes los
invitados se unirán entonces veremos al
presidente de australia también
presidente de la india que se unirá
remotamente suráfrica y además corea del
sur que es bien importante como el g7
trata de acercarse a estos aliados en
asia para contrarrestar el poder de
china